bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
bourg tous et pour ce nouveau numéro de
sion par les sports le talk est
construit comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive du département
vous connaissez pour améliorer à des
coups de gueule des analyses des débats
et des duels quatre chroniqueurs sont en
plateau aujourd'hui sont surmotivés pour
cette émission
ils sont prêts à en découdre
présentation en musique notre premier
chroniqueur est ainsi festif plus
précisément à pistard c'est une légende
de cette émission tout d'abord avec son
palmarès champion d'europe master
lui-même et ses coups de gueule galledou
charrier et savent écrire aujourd'hui
son visage vous avez rial très bien
alors vous avez un petit peu perdu de
vue pour cette émission
oui bah les quelques mois qu'on peut pas
toujours se libérer malheureusement pour
venir chaque plateau en tout cas où vous
avez manquez vous avez manqué aux
téléspectateurs on passe de l'autre côté
à musique c'est un petit à nouveau dans
cette émission il est cavalier
international de niveau 2 étoiles il est
le gérant des écuries du château de
plaisir il a pratiqué le sabre le tennis
la voile et la boxe anglaise également à
où le taux très d'autray et avec nous
aujourd'hui
bonjour bonjour michael injure à tous ce
soir c'est vrai que c'est une toute
première pour moi et je vais progresser
non pas j'écoute et je vais essayer de
gérer ça au mieux et je suis ravi d'être
sur ce plateau parmi vous méfiez vous
dit alors c'est un redoutable quand il
tirait g j'ai remarqué j'ai préparé mes
armes on repasse à droite musique il a
participé aux jeux paralympiques
d'athènes en 2004 en tant que tennisman
vous l'aurez compris il pourrait me
mettre ainsi 0,6 au tennis vu mon niveau
nous vient tout droit de monter votre
mur régis harel et avec cela
l on soit régis est en forme jurée dans
l'émission ça s'est bien passé de votre
première la dernière thé noir meilleur
donc c'est ma deuxième mais non j'ai
trouvé je suis rodé maintenant parfait
on termine notre tour à deux tables par
un rugbyman musique
il a une aura présidentielle nous vient
du rugby-club de versailles l'un des
plus gros club des yvelines n'hésite pas
à aller au conflit pour emporter à les
duels bonjour olivier neuray bonjour
michael bonjour à tous c'est ma deuxième
émission je suis le remplaçant en
général je suis le remplaçant de
quelqu'un de nouveau
la dernière fois fêté guillaume mon fils
mais aujourd'hui fut ravi d'être là
voilà j'espère que en tout cas vous avez
réviser vos fiches pour cette émission
je suis bien préparé j'espère on va
passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler d'équitation les médailles
olympiques peuvent-elles booster le
nombre d'adhérents nous parlons
également des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste qui seront organisés
à saint quentin en yvelines du 19 au 23
octobre mais tout de suite coup de
projecteur sur l'équipe de baseball des
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux puis
on commence donc par du baseball les
cougars de montier bretons ne se
rapproche de la montée en première
division lésigny montrent un devront
s'imposer en finale des play-off contre
saint-just saint-rambert pour accéder à
la division supérieure les deux premiers
matchs de la série se disputeront ce
samedi 24 et dimanche 25 septembre à
saint-just on écoute l'un des joueurs de
l'équipe des cougars alexandre couteau
on a gagné contre eux pendant la saison
régulière on a fini devant au classement
après pendant les phases finales on sait
jamais pas trop confiants effectivement
ça peut être le risque mais non on n'est
pas confiant parce qu'on a vu que
justement saint-just avait fait de
bonnes phases finales et que finalement
les résultats en saison régulière ça va
peut-être rien dire sur une série de 5
matchs et faire leur est sérieux
appliqués jouer dur et rien lâcher
alors j'ai pu rencontrer les joueurs de
mon team retenue avant la rencontre ils
ont gagné quatre matches sur quatre
contre st juste ils sont donc ultra
favori sur cette rencontre
ils sont quasiment sûrs de remporter
cette victoire peut-on être sûr de
remporter une finale
vous votez oui ou non à un petit duel
pour pourra où l'on fait un petit duel à
raul
yann c parti rahul vous commencez alors
moi j'aime hiver pour ne pas mettre
rouge dans le sens où effectivement dans
un langage sportif on ne peut jamais
être sûr de remporter une finale
après c'était pour soulever le fait
qu'ils avaient énormément de facteurs en
leur faveur
quatre matches en cave un caveau 4
victoires en 4 matchs en saison
régulière en saison régulière
c'est le plus grand club de france 2015
ils ont été les premiers à envoyer une
fille mélissa mes yeux aux états ou aux
états unis sur la major baseball league
donc beaucoup d'éléments en leur faveur
il voit aussi effectivement bénéficié de
ryan juarez
seul petit bémol effectivement qui
valait trois rêves qui est leur meilleur
joueur en colère hier un américain qui
vient tout droit d'australie mais qui
est là que pour six mois
donc il ça serait quand même dans leur
désintérêt de de se reposer que sur eux
pour le 6 à une éventuelle montée en
première division
parce qu'apparemment en plus il est sûre
il a il a un poste vraiment décisif
je suis pas un expert en baseball mais
il est dans un poste assez décisif dans
une partie il fait remporter le match
voilà il remplir de ma que j'avais tout
seul en prisé dans leurs réservoirs
quelqu'un de de précieuses voix qui
pourrait le remplacer pour pour une
première division c'était un verre pour
permettre à rouge parce que on n'est
jamais sûr de remporter une finale
évidemment et surtout on est dans un
débat
à vous également comme on dit voilà on
n'est jamais sûr de gagner que ce soit
une finale baseball ou ou un match de
foot ou quoi que ce soit même si on est
ultra favori ben tant pis le coup de
sifflet ou tant que la ligne n'est pas
passé on peut pas se dire que tout et
tout et gagner maintenant
maintenant voilà c'est vrai qu'ils
partent quand même avec un
un bon bagage et un bonne confiance en
deux apparemment vu le discours du
joueur que vous avez voilà il reste
méfiants ils vont aborder ce match avec
avec la concentration et la nécessaire
pour pouvoir le remporter
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir alors
l'avantagent qui a donc maintenant j'ai
confiance vu ce que j'ai compris c'est
qu'il ya cinq matches c'est au meilleur
des cinq matchs ça met un peu
donc même s'il sera du match aller à
domicile la semaine d'après voilà donc
ça veut dire que même s'il se rate sur
sur un des premiers matchs ils auront
quand même moyen de ce2 de se rattraper
sur sur la suite
globalement ils ont quand même un
ballotage très favorable favorable mais
voilà il va falloir être sérieux comme
comme je disais au début du début de mon
intervention qui a raison ou qui a
raison la dore je souhaite moi je sais
qu'il faut jamais avoir un excès de
confiance donc c'est vrai que l'élection
quand on a l'air de dire qui justement
ici méfie donc ça c'est plutôt bien
moi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
donc je pense qu'il devrait film ils
sont quand même assez confiant oui ils
sont assez confiants mais justement à
des fois qu'on est trop trop confiants
qu'on a trop ben là c'est là que nous
apparaissions voilà pour la surprise
voilà donc rester concentré olivier
neyreneuf facteur également à prendre en
contre ils n'ont pas joué depuis trois
mois il va jouer depuis juillet je
dirais quand favori bien sûr sont
favoris mais en plus si c'est au
meilleur des cinq matches si on est
presque dans la foulée régulière ils ont
été gagné quatre fois je pense pas qu'il
a tissé leurs quatre ils peuvent pas
être battus ca serait une finale
un jour j avec une préparation donnée
sur un match bien sûr tout est jouable
parce que finalement l'excès de
confiance
il suffit pas de le proclamer il faut
que mentalement et que ces deux
fonctions sont ne l'est pas donc moi je
pense que même alors le seul bémol c'est
sûr qu'il s'est passé trois mois et il
était qu'est-ce qui s'est passionné ou
la préparation mais je pense que quand
même quatre fois les entraînements mais
pas de match bon elle sert en saison
régulière et sur 5 matchs je pense pas
qu'ils puissent perdre sur les trois
mois il savait à la fin de la saison
régulière qu'ils auraient ces trois mois
de coupure alors petite précision
ils n'ont pas joué de demi-finale juste
à jouer sa demi finale
oui d'accord je me savais bien compris
maintenant voilà il le savait qu'il y
avait ce trou de trois mois
j'espère qu'ils ont su mobiliser tout le
monde pour pouvoir reprendre
l'entraînement suffisamment tôt que tout
le monde a été assidu à l'entraînement
et à partir de là on arrive justement à
être ce que vous expliquez juste avant
qu'on prenne comprennent l'antenne sur
sur trois mois on a moins de faire des
très très bonne préparation est
justement d'avoir un physique
suffisamment suffisant pour est
supérieur à ce qu'on pourrait avoir sur
une saison régulière donc là moi je
pense quand même que en tant que
athlètes qui préparent des essais des
échéances d'avoir comme ça sur deux
week-ends un pic de forme à avoir c'est
très très facile à programmer saint-just
raul a également peut-être progressé
aussi pendant l'intersaison moi je suis
du même on les voyait papa de la
rochelle ils ont finalement battu 3 0
avec des scores 15 à 7 23 14 et 18 à 8
ce ne sont pas des petits scores une
annonce assez charlemagne battu la
rochelle qui était 3e pourtant je pense
qu'à une possibilité qu'ils étaient par
rapport à aux cougars un poil asphyxiés
par les matchs et qu'effectivement une
pause estivale à ce niveau là ça peut
qu'être bénéfique parce que d'abord il
ya un entretien et aménagement du
physique et surtout une possibilité de
se rencontrer sur la technique à mettre
en place pour battre l'adversaire alors
que quand on est en train de de voir des
matchs contre d'autres adversaires peut
pas se permettre de cibler
l'entraînement alors que là il a été
ciblé sur saint-just je pense que ça
fait quand même je pense qu'à ce niveau
là la pause estivale et les queues bonne
et que il irait pas se risquer à se
refroidir et généreux on peut se poser
des questions quand même sur la formule
du championnat quand même si entre dix
finales et finale ils se passent trois
mois je vais dire qu'est ce que ça veut
dire veut dire que la saison régulière
avec le dynamique est enclenchée elle
est tout un coup complètement stoppée il
faut retour des marais donc là c'est
quand même aussi un facteur à prendre en
compte mais je comprends pas d'où cette
forme de championnat le match retour qui
se joue à domicile
est-ce que ça a son importance régis
sahel ben je pense qu'en laissons quand
on est chez soi c'est toujours mieux
pour comment donc je pense qu'ils ont
tout toutes les chances de gagner vous
souvenez ce que j'avais
et comme petite recherche sur la ligue
des champions après les huitièmes de
finale sur les huitièmes qui étaient
étaient joués tous ceux qui recevaient
sur le deuxième match
enfin les valves et avoir noté tout ce
n'est pas bien alors il y avait
énormément énormément de 2,2 mètres deux
clubs qui recevaient sur le sur le sur
le match retour qui qui passait autour
au tour suivant et c'était en parler de
football à ce moment là mais et voilà il
ya un fort et un fort avantage à
recevoir sur sur le match retour bien
sûr il peut pas y avoir également une
peur peut-être giffard l2 de gagner
justement de la peur la peur de gagner
pas de calais ben ça peut arriver aussi
mais je pense qu'ils sont supposés
argent qui sont comme ultra-favori ils
ont connu la première division également
qui sont tués en 2012
oui mais je pense qu'ils vont pas
refaire les mêmes erreurs ils ont envoyé
le le joueur le disait bien ils sont ils
font attention à ce qu'ils disent ils
sont pas hyper enthousiaste on va gagner
on va gagner ils sont maintenant ils
vont gagner c'est pas plus compliqué que
je pense attention la première division
il ya un départ prochain du joueur
américain donc et partir à quoi qu'il
arrive à la fin il parce que c'est ce
que j'ai vu en tous les cas quand je me
suis renseigné il est en fin de contrat
donc
ils sont déjà sans cependant bénéficié
pour cette finale donc attention au
niveau supérieur à montigny régis avaler
ce qu'il peut y avoir une effervescence
autour de ce match où est ce qu'on
pensait que le baseball est encore un
petit peu en deçà du football du rugby
par exemple
non il ne les voyez pas défilée amis du
centre après leur victoire à n'ont
peut-être pas peut-être pas juste que
quand même non mais c'est vrai qu'ils
sont sont pourtant d'air ils sont
pourtant des 1 et sont soutenus par la
municipalité sont soutenus par je pense
tous les spectateurs donc après ce que
ça peu à peu amener une différé sens
comme ça j'en sais rien mais qui
explique que quelque part ils sont
soutenus c'est sûr si on est accompagné
ce n'est pas ce que je trouve dommage
c'est qu'en plus ce stade de baseball
on le voit quand on est sur mon tennis
puisqu'il est au niveau du carrefour qui
est très souvent embouteillée est donc
en iran le voir on passe souvent à côté
à droite là donc on l'a sur la loi donc
je trouve que c'est dommage justement
que ce n'est pas peut-être plus de
communication sur le moment où les
matches les matches se disputent pour
que les gens puissent puissent venir moi
je parce qu'en plus je pense que le
baseball est un sport très sympa à
regarder vous aller les encourager sur
votre tour
match retour je sais pas est ce que je
serai chez vale date parce que je serai
amené ce que je serai dispose c'est pas
gagné on verra ça on continue par du
rugby avec le championnat de fédérale 3
qui a repris le dimanche 18 septembre
pour cette première journée plaisir se
déplacer sur le terrain de viry à
châtillon les yvelinois sont partis avec
une victoire dans leur valise ils ont
dominé leurs adversaires 35 à 23 avec
après une entame de match catastrophique
on écoute l'entraîneur de plaisir gens
disent oh c'est l'entamé la pire qui
puisse exister ça c'est sûr en 2030 on
peut en brun l essai transformé et une
pénalité donc 10 0 et en plus on prend
un essai en 40 secondes en deuxième mi
temps donc les deux entames de mi-temps
ont été catastrophiques
mais après bon c'est vrai qu'on a on a
quand même un petit peu ont mis notre
jeu en place notamment notamment devant
où on a été très pragmatique avec le peu
d'occasions qu'on a eue sur vingt deux
jeunes touchent notamment on est on a
été adam quasiment je dis pas chaque
fois mais presque une victoire
compliquée face à un adversaire
largement à leur portée à plaisir qui a
connu seulement deux défaites la saison
dernière en phase régulière semblent
avoir une poule plus compliqué cette
année selon le coach jean miss viry
chatillon sur un bon adversaire avec des
joueurs venus était un bonne averse avec
des joueurs venus de chevreuse il ya
toujours ris orangis qui sera l'un des
favoris mots qui a fait un gros
recrutement et club yvelinois de houille
genlis se méfie également d'evreux et de
caen bref la qualification en playoffs
s'annonce compliquée vaut-il mieux être
dans une plus forte ou une poule faible
pour le championnat de saison régulière
vous voter ou non poule forte rouge
poupou le faible verts ont fait un petit
duel entre vous olivier nero 9 et mme
royal encore à l'essai imparable c'est
votre tour il faut bien péter alegi
gamme on l'a vu la fin on l'a vu la fin
de l'année dernière plaisir était dans
une poule où ils se sont baladés toute
la saison et quand ils sont arrivés en
phase finale où ils ont rencontré des
adversaires qu'ils étaient
mieux préparés ils ont chuté et ils ont
jeté tout de suite et je me souviens que
parce que le monsieur dont on entend
maintenant j'en lis l'impression d'avoir
déjà vu ce monsieur je vais régler assez
pour ça donc oui je me souviens que oui
il avait vraiment bien bien mis ça en
avant que c'est vrai que les matchs trop
facile pendant toute l'année ça ça
n'aide pas à pouvoir aborder les phases
finales sereinement donc mon cette année
apparemment on a dix ans des dons là
deux discours différents
celui de versailles qui dit que plaisir
aurait plutôt une poule une poule
accessible alors que plaisir se défendre
en disant que certains adversaires vont
également être difficile maintenant moi
je pense que ben ça va se faire sur les
buts à l'extérieur
il commence bien premier match première
victoire à l'extérieur contre un avis il
est fort difficile ça on s'en fout ce
qui comme ses victoires
ce qui compte c'est les trois points et
en plus ils en ont pris quatre car quand
tu vois là c'est parfait
peu importe le résultat c'est la manière
qui nous importe la manière seul le
résultat compte
ça c'est ma devise olivier faire parler
les prisons de versailles sur son club
de plaisir c'est prendre un grand risque
sachant que une rivalité sportive qui a
existé depuis le siècle précédent et je
peux même dire que je me suis fait
exploser le nez sur 1 dans un match en
jouant à l'arrière à plaisir devant la
tribune et sous les boules sous les
hourras de la foule et mais où je dirais
que les histoires de plaisir et de
versailles sont quand même pas
entrecroisées elles sont parallèles
parce que la culture est différente d'un
club à l'autre et donc finalement moi je
pense que ce que si le résultat
important dimanche c'est que mr miss l'a
bien dit il on était pragmatique sur eux
le moment où ils ont été menés moment
ils ont quelques ballons celle là ils
ont montré de l'expérience qu'ils
avaient donc ça veut dire que ils vont
être capables à mon avis sur deux
saisons de pouvoir se retrouver en tête
de la poule
alors évidemment ils ont des adversaires
plus compliqué puisque mon ris orangis
mon avis globalement au même niveau que
l'année dernière maintenant les
orangistes qui les avait battus deux
fois en deux confrontations une dernière
voilà après après mots et viry-châtillon
ils ont disposé de moyens financiers qui
sont arrivées de façon certainement par
des gens qui ont de l'argent donc
finalement ils ont changé un peu
transformé leur équipe etc
ces équipes là vont être un peu à
regarder de très près après ça allez oui
c'est jamais facile parce que oui c'est
une équipe très accrocheuse et quand
aussi allé gagner à caen ou à evreux
quand on vous fait jouer sur le terrain
boueux et pas sur le terrain le stade
officiel là ça devient compliqué il faut
vraiment être supérieur donc je pense
que toute façon c'est tout bénéfice pour
l'équipe du plaisir
vous êtes en train de dire que tous les
matches sont compliqués il ya quelques
adversaires je n'ai pas nommé ça serait
plus facile mais bon globalement mais je
pense que c'est quand même bien mieux
pour la confiance simplement de d'être
obligé de faire l'effort tous les
dimanches raul
qui a raison qui a tort moi je pense
qu'effectivement une poule une poule
assez relevée dès le début ça permet de
se mettre à niveau et de s'échauffer ça
reste un sport de contact dont je pense
que on a besoin de contacts pour entrer
vraiment dans le match
ouais je vais je marche un peu sur un
terrain miné parce que si je dis des
conneries je veux que les avis divergent
et moi je partage en fait il ya dix
mètres nous sépare entre le terrain de
rugby et ma carrière donc si je me mets
à dos tout le match où l'équipe du rugby
club de plaisir vous rendre voilà je
risque d'avoir quelques heureux présage
donc je vais rester assez voilà je vais
voter en tout sur ce sujet là même si
j'ai trouvé d'accord moi je suis
peut-être faire pareil parce qu'il est
son père parents fraîcheur si on a une
poule compliquée pendant toute la saison
ah bah on va on va perdre forcément
fraîcheur mais en sachant qu une saison
c'est long très long mais c'est aussi ce
que plus il ya difficulté plus on doit
être on doit travailler pour pouvoir
pallier difficulté donc après je pense
qu'il fait il faut travailler et puis
c'est tout et puis il faut continuer il
faut il faut bosser et puis on montre et
puis c'est comme ça qu'on atteint qu'on
montre les paliers un con il n'y a pas
de secret si les aborde bien des
missions communes de le faire là
ils pourront peut-être même avoir des
matches un peu plus fins au moins avec
moins dangereux en fin de saison en fin
de saison régulière et donc du coup
pouvoir la série télé c'est pas tout à
fait faire de l'énergie et préparer au
mieux les phases finales mais n'a plus
ce n'est pas une émission ce matin mais
j'ai rencontré le tir il a demandé au
comité des yvelines
donc on a parlé gentiment du match de
dimanche bon il a dit que ça a été
compliqué mais après il ya la fin du
match il disait simplement je regrette
qu'on n'ait pas pris le bonus parce
qu'ils ont fait quatre essais à deux il
n'y a pas eu les cartes locservice marge
qui était important pour le plaisir
puis moi je trouve ce qui est vraiment
important c'est que dans les moments où
ils ont été très pragmatique sur les
ballons qu'ils ont lui et qui est
éventuellement gagner pour marquer des
essais ils ont fait donc là c'est là
l'expérience qu'elle s'est elle manque
d'adversité qui a qui a manqué à plaisir
à une dernière moi je ne peux pas
conclure ça mais je vais dire à partir
du moment où on arrive finalement ils
ont affronté anthony si je me trompe pas
qui vous avez affronté vous en phase de
poules qui nous avait battus oui bien
sûr mais je veux dire dans notre poule
en avait 2 in amant versailles était
dans une poule compliquée dernière vrai
puisqu'on avait deux le 2e et 3e sont
montés en fédérale 2 est le premier qui
était avec dix points d'avancé sur le
deuxième et le troisième est pas monté a
été battu par anthony avant plaisir avec
est battu par anthony donc c'est une
poule guerrière l'année dernière mais je
pense que c'est vrai qu'ils avaient pas
si combat dans la poule 2 le plaisir et
plaisir et russes orangis point barre
bouriane vous préfère vous entraîner et
ont affronté des personnes fortes des
cyclistes de haut niveau ou plutôt gagné
une course facilement alors non gagné
facilement sait jamais at-elle à vaincre
sans péril on triomphe sans gloire donc
sage
je reste je reste là dessus maintenant
il faut les deux il faut pouvoir se
confronter à du très haut niveau pour
pour l'être lors dès lors des échéances
que l'on peu ce que l'on peut se fixer
et il faut aussi pouvoir emmagasiner un
peu de confiance
j'en discutais avec la fan de kévin
sireau
du moins sa star de l'équipe de france
par l'équipe de france et justement nous
là on va au championnat du monde dans
quinze jours eh ben on a fait zéro
compétition contre contre nos futurs
adversaires on sait pas sur qui on va
tomber
on connaît pas leur niveau donc ça va
être la grande surprise dans dix jours
mais bon on fait avec et par contre
voilà je suis assez serein parce que les
chronos aux entraînements sont bons on
vous suivra
attention contient il ya le plaisir aura
plus de mérite peut-être raul à sortir
d'une poule compliquée de remporter le
championnat afin d'aller d'aller
jusqu'en haut d'aller jusqu'à la montée
alors il y aura les playoffs après où je
pense que
dans un tournoi comme celui là les
joueurs se transcendent donc le chemin
sera long mais effectivement il rompt si
la poule est compliqué effectivement de
les gros les grosses échéances à
surmonter derrière eux mais ce com
comme le disait notre notre chroniqueur
versailles et c'est pas c'est pas tout
repos donc voilà ça sera un mot de la
fin après sept pages résultat coup de
projecteur sur le cyclisme sur piste
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste seront organisées au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
19 au 23 octobre ce sera la deuxième
fois que la structure accueillera une
compétition internationale de cyclisme
après les championnats du monde 2015 on
écoute le président de la fédération
française david lappartient
il ya d'abord une logique d'accueillir
de grands événements on a la chance
d'avoir un vélodrome exceptionnel
quand on a vu l'élan qu'on a eue au
championnat du monde on a eu envie
évidemment de continuer à voir des
grands événements on avait cette
opportunité puisque 2017 étaient déjà
attribués à berlin 2018 à glasgow et on
a saisi l'opportunité
fallait-il organiser les championnats
d'europe
cette année vous votez oui ou non oui à
olivier nero 9 ont fait un petit duel
contre régis harel qui connaît bien
aussi c'est parti pour ben moi je peux
pas lutter et là on nie pas sa part de
mal à parler en francs sera après non je
pense que c'est toujours délicat de
faire un championnat d'une très très
haut niveau
juste après une une compétition comme
les deux olympiques alors bon est-ce que
les est-ce que l'engouement va être
capable d'être présent est ce que la
comédie est ce que les gens vont se
déplacer
est-ce que les gens alors peut-être on
va dire à l'esprit de revanche peut-être
dépisteurs
l'orgueil va être capable ont réalisé
qu'une seule médaille de bronze sur la
compétition est-ce que l'orgueil va être
capable de transcender pour que
finalement laissé pistard l'équipe
puisse montrer que vraiment ce qui s'est
passé au jeu c'était pas vraiment ce qui
aurait dû se passer maintenant
je pense quand même c'est prendre un
risque parce que peut-être est-ce que
les ténors sont là est-ce que les
victoires seront vraiment des victoires
valorisante
personnellement j'ai pas suivi le
dossier donc je pose simplement des
points d'interrogation et donc après
c'est aux gens c'est officer de parler
de ça va s'cauet tavaux ben moi je pense
que c'est une bonne dose de bonnes
choses qu'on championnats d'europe après
effectivement et je pense qu'il va y
avoir un sursaut d'orgueil parce qu'avec
les résultats de
de riou c'était un peu ils s'attendaient
à quand même à beaucoup mieux donc
maintenant et quand quand un général un
sportif il était piqué ou ici rajit
normalement donc que et puis ils ont
tellement un bel écrin non avec ce
vélodrome que ça serait ce serait
dommage de ne pas en profiter il vous
était forcément favorable à
l'organisation du championnat d'europe
pourquoi parce que ce fait le drone
comme c'est du délire c'est un superbe
outil que quand il ya 5000 personnes qui
vivent derrière derrière les cyclistes
français et ben c'est cesser c'est
énorme quand vous entendez pas le
speaker parler dans le micro
parce que les gens crient derrière
derrière mais derrière les athlètes moi
j'ai pris un pied énorme pendant les
championnats du monde de l'année
dernière alors que était juste juste
spectateurs mais voilà c'était c'était
juste mieux c'était vraiment énorme
maintenant moi cela ou pourquoi je
trouve que c'est bien de les organiser
en france c'est que fin des organismes
simplement c'est que ça va être les
l'appartien disait qu'il y avait une
date de libre en fait en quelque sorte
c'est bien on l'a on l'a prise et tant
mieux tant mieux pour tendu par le
vélodrome et tant mieux pour nous
maintenant moi ce que j'espère sur ces
championnats c'est que la dtn va
va se mettre en place pour les
prochaines échéances et donc faire
rentrer nos petits jeunes normalement
j'ai entendu dire que la sélection se
ferait sur les championnats de france
qui vont avoir lieu le week-end prochain
du 27 septembre au 2 octobre et donc
normalement voilà c'est là que la
sélection se fait pour les championnats
d'europe qui auront lieu quinze jours
après donc
j'espère que c'est ce qui va
véritablement se passer et que l'on
pourra à voir apparaître nos petits
jeunes qui sont sébastien vigier méline
en berne ots qui sont deux jeunes
déjantés
quant à la farine les plus jeunes quant
à 24 ans apporte quoi pas content je
pense que voilà il avait alors dit le
champion de france champion de france de
vitesse depuis deux ans il a est une
qu'une envie c'est de le rester j'ai vu
à l'entraînement cet été et voilà donc
c'est ça fait partie de ces objectifs
d'aller aux championnats d'europe de
participer aux championnats d'europe
donc pour moi quentin sera sera qualifié
il n'y a pas donné pas de problème mais
ce que ce que j'aimerais c'est voir
justement ces petits jeunes qui ont 18
et 19 ans qui commence à marquer des
points en coupe du monde
sébastien viger a gagné une coupe du
monde le portugal au mois de juin je
crois donc vous allez laisser la place
vraiment cette nouvelle génération est
bien sûr
françois à 35 ans à pervis 50 ans et
voilà françois et grégory baugé en 35
ans sur la prochaine olympiade
voilà il faut y aller pour moi y'a que
michael kiki 15 mai d'anciennes week end
les médias qui accueille sa place pour
rester dans l'équipe 2 qui est un peu
plus jeune il a 29 ans chauffard 28 et
en effet c'est pour moi c'est voilà il
faut tourner la page il faut qu'on passe
à autre chose maintenant ce qu'il faut
aussi c'est que françois pervis et
grégory baugé accompagne justement ces
jeunes athlètes pour acquérir
l'expérience suffisante et acquérir le
haut niveau faut que le fonds conserve
de ces de ces deux de ces de la tête
qu'il faut fibrer pour noël pendant des
années raul il faut vraiment tourné la
page ces jeux olympiques et repartir sur
une nouvelle dynamique avec des jeunes
ah oui je pense que le renouveau c'est
toujours important dans le sport a
pressé je reviens sur je rejoins
reviennent sur sur ce point là c'est une
bonne chose que que cet événement soit
réorganisée en plus ils peuvent tirer
conséquent ils peuvent se reposer sur
les acquis des championnats du monde et
des actes manqués de cet événement là
les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes 25000
spectateurs
là on attend 28 nations je crois que
c'est ça plus de 200 athlètes donc et
manquera seulement les néo zélandais les
australiens avaient colombien les
américains eux n'ont apparemment de les
grands grands cyclistes à reviennent
d'europe
ce qu'on espère c'est que le sport
puisse générer plus de sponsors parce
que si je crois si je me souviens que
ces deux tiers du budget a été financée
par le pouvoir public parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une discipline qui a
encore du mal à trouver des sponsors
donc c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on leur
souhaite pour pour continuer à organiser
des événements cette envergure et le
wiener 9 est ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aura un niveau spectaculaire pendant ces
championnats d'europe en sachant qu'il
ya eu les championnats du monde
en début d'année à londres il ya
également les jeux olympiques est ce que
vous pensez qu'il y aura du spectacle et
que les têtes d'affiché ne seront pas
trop fatigué de toute façon on respecte
pas qu'il existe avec les pisteurs donc
je pense que vous êtes un ami mais il ya
toujours du spectacle
maintenant je pense que ça aurait
peut-être une bonne idée de de mettre en
avant ces jeunes et de communiquer alors
ses frais communiqua à fond sur ce
championnat du monde avec la relève qui
vient
ir accompagnés par les autres et mais
c'est aussi mettre aussi une pression
tout de suite sur ces jeunes parce que
si on fait chante n'en sont capables de
gérer ils vont déjà il pratique voilà
répit
ils ont déjà fait des championnats
d'europe et championnat du monde
espoir tout ça voilà il n'y a pas de
problème ils demandent que ça
moi je les côtoie ils montrent que ça il
faut absolument qu'il ya une
communication forte qui soit faite sur
le c'est la relève qui démarre et cnf
qui prend le pouvoir et pour fermer et
en efface des tablettes
grégory baugé belge efface pas il va
accompagner le mouvement il doit avec là
justement pour montrer avec toute la
bonhomie et la sympathie qui sont
derrière et qui passe le flambeau ce
passe comme ça c'est fait mais comme ça
c'est fait quand florian rousseau est
parti florian rousseau est pas et ils
les ont accompagnés grégory était déjà
en équipe de france à ce moment là et
c'est lui qui a transmis le flambeau et
il faut que ça se fasse de la même
message de taymans il ya trois mois je
vais juste un petit mot pour pour tous
les saint quentinois
il reste des places je me suis je me
suis renseigné aujourd'hui faut un peu
se précipiter pour sa part seul mais
j'espère que je veux de rome sera plein
il faut que le groupe soit plaint parce
que c'est vraiment un super spectacle et
et quand on est dans l'ambiance allait
elle et elle est juste énorme
il faut que ce soit plein et il faut que
que quand soit derrière nos derrières
nos français derrière nos bleus pour
pour cette échéance
donc hop sur le site du vélodrome pour
pour la réservation
le message est passé on passe maintenant
à notre rubrique débats
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
pas reparlé équitation dans cette
émission la france a brillé pendant les
jeux olympiques avec trois médailles
dont deux en or au brésil
notre débat du jour une médaille
peut-elle booster le nombre d'adhérents
peut-il y avoir un effet gio vous votez
oui ou non partager ian on va faire un
petit duel entre vous raul et régis
labeaume en fait partie régis faut
commencer
moi je pense qu'une médaille ça booste
toujours un sport quel qu'il soit on
peut reprendre des on peut prendre des
références comme en 83 avec la victoire
de noah le tennis après été boostées
après le judo avec deux commandes la vie
de tout y est on a maintenant le
toujours le judo avec eux note notre
conte à l'athlète
voilà il était arrêté il est tellement
grand contre teddy riner voilà tout à
fait et à chaque fois qu'on a eu un
sport qui a brillé avec le hand ball ou
un truc comme ça
systématiquement il ya eu un retour un
effet un effet de où les gens viennent
se licencier juste derrière en général
ça a toujours été comme ça donc pour
l'équitation je pense que ça peut être
la même chose alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais c'est parce que
la question
elle était un petit peu plus précise
c'était ont par rapport au nombre
d'adhérents et lé il ya énormément de
l'aveyron dans l'équitation et déjà
beaucoup on en est à sept cent mille
troisième sport national premier féminin
22500 dans les yvelines
voilà donc c est le sport vision de
l'adhérence se porte bien et n'est pas
nécessiteux maintenant il faut
différencier l'équitation de loisir et
l'équitation sportive
il ya un vrai paradoxe dans le milieu du
cheval qui est qui et qui existent
peut-être aussi dans d'autres formes et
moins
dans cette pièce voilà c'est qu'il y en
a une politique fédérale qui a beaucoup
favorisé les centres équestres et donc
qui a dopé le nombre d'adhérents c'est
très très bien mais qui a laissé un peu
de côté le haut niveau qui ont qu'on a
laissé un petit peu dans son aspect
élitiste et inaccessible skin path qui
est malheureux 1 ce qui nourrit
aujourd'hui le sport de haut niveau en
équitation
c'est le commerce de chevaux et les
grands groupes événementiel donc là où
souvent les verts qu'il ya un côté plus
loisirs qui a été appuyée plus tôt car à
côté compétition complètement en dehors
de la compétition c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui mois que toi dans mon
centre équestre des cavaliers de très
très bon niveau qui sont incapables de
me citer 50 cavaliers internationaux
même français donc l'apport dans le
sport par rapport aux médailles il est
là mais justement c'est plus dans le
dans leurs accords que va faire le les
médailles entre le sport de haut niveau
et les cavaliers et c'est ce dont on a
besoin c'est cette volonté chez les
pratiquants de faire de la compétition
pour que y ait une demande de faire du
concours qui est un réservoir de
cavaliers qui est là on est une nation
de chevaux de premier plan depuis des
siècles avec une grande école ont fait
naître à mon sens les meilleurs chevaux
du monde pour le sport mais il manque un
petit peu comme dans les autres sports
d'american dream c'est à dire que tous
les cavaliers venus viennent pas jamais
nulle pa soit ce sont des fils de soie
ils ont énormément d'argent soit ils
sont nés dans le milieu équestre
on aimerait un petit peu voire des
cavaliers qui viennent de nulle part qui
ont commencé par revenir au poney club
comme les enfants que je reçois chez moi
et c'est ça qui manque alors c'est grâce
à ces médailles et c'est pas nous les
français sont déjà vice-champion du
monde juste avant et vice-champion
d'europe donc il son fils
ils se sont prépondérants sur la phase
internationale depuis depuis longtemps
mais c'est pas encore acquis il faut
qu'il y ait encore des gens comme comme
vous michael qui qui souligne les
résultats de nos champions et qu'il est
médiatise de plus en plus il ya un
progrès mais c'est pas encore ça
on est assez mérité et ya pas encore ses
moyens mis en place comme dans les
autres pays comme la hollande ou comme
là
l'allemagne où le gouvernement dépense
des frais pour que les chevaux restent
en france nous nos chevaux de haut
niveau on est obligé de les vendre et
les états unis viennent de faire leur
marché chez nous les qataris est pareil
donc il faut qu'on puisse garder nos
très bons chevaux pour équiper nos
cavaliers et se maintenir alors on se
maintient mais c'est grâce à des mécènes
qui dépensent beaucoup d'argent pour si
ces gens aujourd'hui arrête enlèvent
leur argent du haut niveau l'équipe de
france s'écroule et c'est très
malheureux quand même il faut une
véritable nouvelle politique par les
catalans si c'est pas que c'est parce
que viendra je le rejoins mais à 100%
parce que c'est pas que tu en équitation
moi vous prenez le vélo vous allez en
vallée de chevreuse tous les dimanches
vous avez des dizaines et des centaines
et des milliers de personnes qui font du
vélo le dimanche en belgique heureuse et
sur les compétitions qui peuvent se
déroule il ya de moins en moins de monde
vous prenez la course à pied c'est
pareil il ya de moins en moins demande
même si c'est des sports qui sont qui
sont peu coûteux je parle le conseil ne
soit pas du vélo mais là où moi je
disais j'étais un peu lent bémol par
rapport à ça est ce que ça va apporter
des licenciés pour moi mon regard de
l'équitation c'est que c'est un sport
cher je sais pas si c'est vrai ou paris
se démocratise petit à petit mais il ya
un prix qu'on pourra pas atteindre parce
que ce sont des faux il faut les nourrir
mieux les soigner il faut les faits
récession des années donc il ya des
frais alors ça se démocratise justement
c'est la fédération qui qui qui avance
là-dessus on crée de nouvelles
disciplines
ça avance mais effectivement ça reste un
sport cher on en est conscient pratiquer
le cyclisme ce qui est loin d'être un
sport qui ne coûte rien sur un peu mon
manque aussi un vrai cheval
ouais vous pouvez peut-être oui on en
croit les calculs à paris
parfois l'un des cols parce que alors
quand il s'agit des chevaux de haut
niveau ce alors là je vois là le prix
d'un cheval pour les jeux olympiques la
moyenne et 39 ont mis au jour joint
c'est vrai que on a un problème en
france sur la pratique du sport en
compétition on pratique savoir mais on
ne pratique pas en compétition et c'est
là qu'il faut les autorités ou faut
trouver des idées pour que les gens
fassent de la complète les nerfs à la
fin la réponse elle tient dans laquelle
des recommandations à la direction de la
jeunesse et sports de la cohésion
sociale
quand vous voulez développeurs des
actions de santé national développement
sportif la compétition n'intéresse
personne
on vous dit sport de masse féminin et
seniors donc c'est là où il faut mettre
l'impact et le pack est donc finalement
on contient une course comme paris
versailles dimanche prochain aura lieu
ce dimanche est y avoir je sais pas
pratiquement vingt mille personnes qui
vont courir très bien mais aller
chercher les grands champions
aujourd'hui les grandes du cours de
français de 5000 et 10000 m où sont ils
il n'y a plus ou n'a pas donc ces
problèmes de la le sport de compétition
un sport de masse
bien sûr c'est beaucoup plus rassurant
pour tout le monde de mettre un peu
d'argent en saut du port de masse
maintenant on abandonne les literies
l'élite il faut éventuellement qu'elle
aille se former ailleurs ou à
l'extérieur où évidemment ça coûte de
l'argent
c'est ce qui avait été révélé c'est ce
qui a été révélé en région où certains
athlètes aux jeux olympiques viva et 500
euros par mois c'est pas c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal
il devrait pas se soucier du matériel
quand ils sont là pour défendre pour
défendre nos couleurs
sara lee a également fait naître une
part aussi médiatique dans voilà le
l'expansion du nombre de licenciés
l'équitation dans un très peu parlé on a
beaucoup parlé de la boxe on a beaucoup
parlé des autres médailles françaises de
l'athlétisme mais finalement peu de
l'équitation
oui peu de l'équitation il ya plein
d'autres sports qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé aussi
il ya toujours de la voile par exemple
la voile ou et après on peut prendre le
canoë-kayak on en a parlé un petit peu
parce qu'il y avait un tony estanguet
daher qui est que son image était là
mais après il ya plein de sports qu'on
l'aviron n'en parle pas beaucoup plus
que ça on en a parlé et c'est des gens
des scores très très dur et des très dur
et la préparation et d'ornements de
préparation et ils n'ont pas non plus
les moyens de il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
derrière de sponsors réel derrière c'est
eux c'est pour tout le monde pareil moi
quand j'ai quand je suis allé au giro en
donc j'ai rencontré des gens qui sortait
justement du canoë kayak et donc il
avait exactement les mêmes problèmes de
médiatisation que nous on paralympiques
on avait à cette époque c'était leur
problème pas deux mais pas de moyens et
pas de méditer de médiatisation
donc en général tout ou suis en certes
ce qui est là où je enfin voilà où on va
pouvoir parler c'est qu'on a une chaîne
qui maintenant l'équipe
la chaîne l'équipe par exemple qui
commence qui va retransmettre les matchs
de
pour l'heure
fédéral l'une à partir de la semaine
prochaine mais j'aurais dû rugby on en
voit tout le temps on a le tournoi des
cimes des destinations non prend on n'a
pas besoin de voir du rugby à la télé on
est d'accord c'était génial en gros il
faut faire actionner une petite avoir
avoir un peu mais l'issue est bien sûr
elle devrait montrer des sports moins
médiatisé et et lassana permettrait
d'avoir donné de la visibilité
eurosport va retransmettre les
championnats de france la 1re sport 2 va
retrouver des championnats de france de
cyclisme sur piste la semaine prochaine
alléluia j'ai fait un peu trop de pub
pour les autres on va pas on va passer à
raul raul pour rapprocher un petit peu
nos champions de nos jeunes pratiquants
pour susciter une envie de partir en
compétition et ensuite là c'est pas
vraiment la faute du média mais que le
système fédéral change pour que des
fonds soient soient soient générés pour
pour garder nos chevaux et qu'on puisse
équiper nos cavaliers parce que le haut
niveau pour l'instant décourage les
pratiquants et olivier rapidement fait
inquiétant ce que vous dites d'ailleurs
c'est que si les gens les pratiquants
sont pas capables de citer les médaillés
olympiques ou des champions non c'est
très simple c'est très très très belle
manière très problématique
c'est un sport aussi qui est très
féminin comité féminin est ce qui nous
parlera peut-être de marché j'aurais dû
dire ça pour attirer les garçons
une fois tu manges sa santé les
médailles ont été remportées par les
garçons mais voilà parce que je scinde
en deux une deuxième heure encore une
fois si vous parlez du loisir
effectivement 80 80 % de filles si vous
me parlez du haut niveau ça commence à
s'équilibrer mais il ya encore vingt ans
étaient 80% d'hommes
parce que les les les cavaliers de haut
niveau ne sont pas que cavaliers se sont
tous des gérants d'entreprises qui
financent eux-mêmes leur leurs chevaux
maintenant on a la chance d'avoir un
système de propriétaires et sponsors qui
achètent les chevaux mais ce sont des
gens qui construisent une écurie qui la
met en place pour être sur la scène
internationale et accéder à des grands
événements comme cela est bon et c'est
un milieu d'extérieur donc c'est un
métier rugueux ont fait face au froid
donc effectivement je fais pas du tout
de mise au 6 mai il ya une résistance
qui est commune en tous les cas aux
hommes qui fait qui perdure plus dans le
sport professionnel
mais aujourd'hui les femmes s'imposent
de belle manière en tous les cas dans
dans l'équitation de haut niveau mais la
majorité tournent un petit peu dès qu'on
passe du côté professionnel c'est ce que
je lis bien quand je regardais quand on
joue justement c'était le fait de se
dire qu' il y avait une médaille par
discipline et c'était hommes femmes
confondus se trouvait ça s'est très très
bien
moi je trouvais que cette plante de
heureusement parce que le talent féminin
dans ce sport il
il est incontestable et elle parle même
je pense avec un léger avantage parce
qu'elles peuvent pas s'imposer par la
force
elles doivent faire preuve de patience
et avec un animal comme le cheval c'est
indispensable
ce hameau de la fin sur ce thème sur ce
débat on continue cette émission avec
les jeux ea paralympiques
les jeux paralympiques de rio se sont
clôturées ce dimanche 18 septembre la
france a emporté 28 médailles et termine
12e au tableau des médailles
quentin keita licenciés pendant de
nombreuses années a lieu à saint quentin
a remporté l'or sur le 400 m l'illinois
louer radius 36 ans également brillé sur
les terrains auriverde est le sportif
champion d'europe et vice-champion du
monde du 1500 m t 38 atteint d'une
hémiplégie gauche remporte la médaille
de bronze en maths les tisserands se
classant derrière le tunisien abbès
saïdi l'australien des hommes kenzy en
écoute les jeux sont réussis oui puisque
je ramène une médaille
j'aurais pu très bien terminé 4e 5e ou
voir tous
donc oui les jeux sont son sont plutôt
réussis après derrière
j'espérais ne l'espérais j'espérais plus
en vue des séances que j'ai fait au
niveau du stade terminal
donc voilà donc oui oui les jeux
sensibles comme on l'a entendu louis
radius viser l'or sur cette compétition
est-ce qu'il doit se satisfaire de cette
médaille d'or aux bronzes qu'il a
remportés pendant pendant ces jeux vous
votez oui ou non un côté rouge un côté
vers raul
vous commencez une yann vous continuez
raul moi je pense qu'il peut s'en
satisfaire d'abord
il ya le combat contre le handicap ça je
pense que c'est la leçon de ce sport
dans son aspect le plus sublime
ensuite ils ont affaire là à un médaillé
récidivistes voilà tous les championnats
auxquels il a participé il n'a jamais
fait pire que le bronze
donc après je reconnais ces cours sont
assez frustrante parce que c'est un
c'est un vrai spécialiste des contre
c'est à dire que dans les 80 derniers
mètres il a toujours une un contre
fulgurant et nous laisse penser qu'il va
gagner à chaque fois il se retrouve à
chaque fois en tous les cas aux jeux
olympiques il se retrouve derrière et
puis faut regarder le moi j'ai vu le
premier interview qui était très
émouvant après après sa médaille
la leçon d'humilité ir mais il devrait
commencer par mears et tout le monde lui
demande s'il est déçu de sa médaille il
dit non pas du tout alors là je vois
dans l'interview il ya un petit recul
ils n'ont pas du tout il remercie tout
le monde et surtout il y 2 de porter un
regard sur les jeux olympiques de 2024
en france des jeux olympiques évidemment
qui bat qu'il ne concerne pas donc
grande leçon d'humilité un homme qui qui
représentait le froid avant tout la
france donc nous en tous les cas je
pense que c'est notre devoir de se
satisfaire de cette médaille ensuite lui
avec l'exigence qu'il a vis-à-vis lui
même qui soit satisfait ou pas d'accord
mais je pense que on pouvait pas
demander mieux de ce tome là moi c'est
vraiment mon coup de coeur sur ces
débats là certains cantons comme
l'annoncent comme ça non ce que souhaite
être premier et je termine 2e ou 3e la
partie à la deuxième place je suis déçu
donc parce que après oui je suis déçu
mais ça n'empêche que je mets en place
tous les moyens
nouvelle médaille au bout oui d'accord
mais il voulait lors voulais l'or donc
moi à sa place et on ne ressent dans son
discours oui maintenant il ya une pointe
de une pointe de déception
je pense qu'il est tout fait pour aller
chercher l'or et bien le jour j ça a pas
ça a pas ça pas scorer bon voilà on est
médaillé on est sur le podium c'est un
moindre mal c'est vrai que mais quand on
est quand on veux l'or et qu'on repart
avec autre chose c'est quand même ça ça
peut rester en travers de la gorge et je
peux le comprendre surtout peut-être que
comme tu dis il est enfin de peut-être
en fin de carrière et donc quand tu en
voilà et donc qu'il aura 2024 il me
semble qu'il faut construire grèce si
l'urss l'olympiade d'un tant mieux pour
pouvoir se rattraper mais c'est ça de
prendre c'est que sur les olympiades
d'un il n'y a qu'une échéance tous les
quatre ans quand il faut pas se rater
voilà et c'est tout et c'est toute la
difficulté de du sport du sport en
général âgés salon était du côté diane
on pense vote
obama mouz est convaincu que non mais je
suis du côté diane morin oui oui parce
que c'est quand on va chercher on va
chercher la médaille d'or on va chercher
la médaille d'or on va pas effectivement
on est même si on a une médaille mais là
pas la même couleur
c'est toujours bien mais on est parti
pour un on s'est battu on a travaillé
pour ça on pensait qu'on allait la voir
et puis là il est c'est vrai qu'il est
enfin de peut-être en fin de parcours
donc pour pour lui c'est terminé sa
carrière comme ça s'arrêtait sort est
exceptionnel dont il peut avoir un vrai
regret après effectivement sur le sur le
fait que après quand il a fini sa course
qui qui vise déjà de 2024 mais ça c'est
giresse est ce un état d'esprit je pense
dans le handisport où on est
mais mon douanière jusqu'à 2024 sera
compliqué ça va être compliqué mais ça
pourrait le faire parce que dans le
handicap le l'écart de d'âgés différents
on n'a pas le même
le même vécu moi j'ai réussi à aller aux
jeux j'avais 40 ans et c'était y avait
encore un polonais nous avait plus de 50
ans qui était dans le tennis parce que
nous la difficulté n'est pas la même là
le apr on joue plus de la technique on a
de l'endurance l'endurance pure vie
qu'on a d'endurance pratiquement donc
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
disciplines de sprint les 500 même sens
il prête il est aussi prêt il participe
aussi aux championnats de france de
cross-country quelqu'un de très complet
comme je pars quand je parlais de 1024
s'était pas par rapport à sa
participation c'était le fait que
justement on lui demande de parler de
lui et le gars il est inouï nous dit
porter les yeux sur la sur les jeux
olympiques
faisons tout pour qu'il se passe en
france moi je trouve que c'est une belle
leçon d'humilité que c'était plutôt des
mentalités mais oui mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on a aussi défendu de moins en
2004 con de paris 2012
on est exactement dans la même dynamique
et en fait c'est le mouvement handisport
était pratiquement le seul qui a été à
100% tout le temps derrière ça a été
assez candidature parce que derrière il
ya aussi autre chose il ya le sport ne
pour n'importe quel portif que que les
justes passa à londres à barcelone peu
importe à tokyo on en a un peu rien à
faire agir et après pour le prêt de nous
si ça se passe en france déjà rend là le
public français qui va être là mais
c'est que derrière il ya autre chose qu
on a derrière nous c'est que quand une
ville reçoit ou un pays reçoit il doit
se rendre accessible entièrement et nous
notre vision elle est là elle est
derrière aussi c'est que ça l'est les
valides oublie souvent mais c'est en
2012 quand on a perdu les par le paris
2012 nous on a perdu tout
l'accessibilité aussi et ça c'était
énorme ya l'on pense à akwa le soir
quand on rentre de l'hôtel et qu'on
pense à la compétition à son échec
on pense à quoi ça dépend comment on
prend là elle après la course il a pris
comme un échec il est vrai je suis
médaillé donc il est allé faire la fête
et puis il ya tout le monde qui est
autour et qui vous et qui vous êtes vous
vous êtes déçu mais à côté on vous
vous remontre le mois en vous disant hey
c'est une médaille
là vous étiez vous étiez combien d vous
étiez combien au départ tout le monde ne
peut pas avoir la médaille
donc voilà il ya quand même des phrases
mais mais
par la suite houlalala la déception et
la question peut rester voilà je pense
qu'il a quand même montré qu'il était un
vrai champion parce que il a il a montré
qu'il a pris le recul par rapport à son
expérience d'avant le professeur de de
tout ce qu'il a fait et en plus il a
honoré les jeux olympiques en disant
finalement qu'il était heureux de voir
sa médaille
même si probablement intérieurement il y
dénonce et thala après quand il y est on
interviewe plus tard là ça revient mais
mais sur le moment il a été a été un
vrai championnat était il a honoré sur
la carrière qu'il a à chaque fois qu'il
participe à un championnat
moi c'était parce que la question
c'était peut-on se satisfaire nous
poteau ça donne jamais de bruit 8
peut-être non mais nous en satisfaire
semaine alors que moi je les prie en
voilà si c'est ça c'est après cette page
paralympiques
nous allons passer à notre sport
découverte le handball en fauteuil
aujourd'hui notre rubrique découverte
coup de projecteur sur leur handball en
fauteuil une discipline pratiquée dans
seulement deux clubs d'île de france
dont montigny-le-bretonneux avec
quelques entraînements également à
elancourt présentation de ce sport je
suis allé à la rencontre du coach de la
section b bonjour thierry bonjour
michael bienvenus merci merci
m'accueillir à montigny-le-bretonneux
alors ça va se passer comment
aujourd'hui alors voilà en fait vous
allez participer à un entraînement
classique
de hand fauteuil voilà donc là vous avez
l'équipe qui est en train de s'échauffer
qui est en train d chauffer le gardien
de manière classique comme n'importe
quel entraînement de sport on a un
fauteuil
comment il fonctionne ce fauteuil j'ai
l'impression qu'il est plus rapide car
peut-être classique alors il est plus
rapide parce que
vous avez déjà dedans des sportifs donc
ce sont tous des joueurs et des joueuses
qui effectivement déjà en quelques
années d'entraînement donc effectivement
ils ont la capacité à faire avancer
assez vite le fauteuil
la différence avec un fauteuil de ville
par exemple ces verrous qui sont
inclinés les roues qui il roule incliné
nous permettre deux choses une meilleure
stabilité et surtout aussi de pouvoir
tourner beaucoup plus vite sur soi même
étant donné que on a besoin de change de
changement de votre mobile il faut être
très mobile
exactement voilà vous avez des
protections
au niveau des pieds de manière à ce qu
effectivement comme les chocs sont
possibles au hand fauteuil comme le onze
classique c'est à sart est un sport de
contact
c'est bien effectivement on a des pare
chocs pour protéger les passe droits
c'est un sport de contact ça reste un
sport de contact à la différence qu
effectivement on autorise les contacts
de face
de manière à ce que le joueur puisse
vous arriver l'adversaire et puis se
préparer à l'impact
tout simplement on interdit mais là
aussi comme dans le handball valide les
chocs par le côté est bien plus on les
chope par l'arrière parce que là c'est
très dangereux
je précise qu'il n'y a pas que les non
valides qui peuvent participer à ce
sport est également les valides qui
peuvent participer
vous votez oui ou non vous pourriez
essayer le handball fauteuil
oui ou non parce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser ici essayé je dis bien de
tous d'accord pourquoi y'a parce que moi
je suis adepte de toutes nouvelles
expériences tout simplement et que et
puis et que j'ai déjà fait du basket en
fauteuil d'ailleurs pas parfaite mais
basket en fauteuil je me souviens après
une rando alors la sensation même c'est
marrant c'est non c'est marrant c'est
voilà deux et puis de voir que bas sont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus agile
que nous puisque on n'a pas l'habitude
de se déplacer avec le fauteuil
et puis après il ya aussi toute la
partie technique et se dire que bah
voila quand il décide de faire une passe
la balle elle va là où ils ont décidé
alors que vous vous êtes perturbé par le
fauteuil
il ya énormément de choses à apprendre
en compte et donc non moi je ne pourrais
pas allez allez allez faire un
entraînement quoi sert elle vous avez
déjà faire un match de handball fauteuil
j'ai fait plus qu'un match il a rappelé
10 km parce que j'ai participé en fait
tous au développement du vally de la
section donc d'autres fauteuils donc
j'en faisais partie au départ mais moi
c'est un manque de temps qui fait que je
m'entraîne pas avec eux mais les
entraîneurs avaient emmené jeff héroïque
beaucoup entre nous on a fait des
matches exhibition aussi à paris
ou paris saint-germain donc non non
c'était non c'est si tu fais comment moi
le problème c'est que moi je viens du
tennis où on doit se déplacer très vite
et ce sur le terrain donc c'est pour moi
c'est quelque chose de sympa donc moi je
retrouve énormément de plaisir à
pratiquer sa donc après pour invalides
qui s'assoit dans le fauteuil en général
dit après l'entraînement il s'aperçoit
qu'il avait des muscles existait pas
avant et qui lui font mal en termes
c'est surtout ça après mai mais
autrement c'est ça permet de mettre tout
le monde au même niveau et puis après ça
c'est un vrai plaisir
raul vous pourriez tester au mois oui
avec plaisir
d'un certain point de vue quand on a
l'esprit sportif il ya le set cet esprit
de combativité et on peut même parfois
être un petit peu envieux des gens qui
font face au handicap parce qu'ils font
preuve d'une combativité qu'on qu'on n'a
pas parce qu'on n'est pas l'occasion de
ce ne se présente pas de la généré donc
se mettre à leur place l'espace d'un
instant pour se mettre à leur niveau je
pense que c'est quelque chose que ça
c'est sûr il a également dû contacter
olivier neyreneuf comme au rugby
oui mais ça glisse ça aussi le rugby en
fauteuil ça existe avocats une section
d'ailleurs qu'elle était aux jeux
paralympiques
oui une section qui se développe qui est
bien développée à maisons-laffitte
saint-germain précis et avec les
démonstrations qui sont en temps elle
encourt justement solitaire anna et
c'est vrai que il ya aussi des valides
qui participe avec les non valides et
c'est un peu compliqué surtout pour les
valides parce que c'est vrai qu'il faut
apprendre à conduire le en fait la
tension et polar est né là dessus et
finalement les autres ils sont publics
plus efficaces donc mais franchement je
ne suis déjà monté dans un fauteuil une
seule fois j'ai coup j'ai pu réaliser
que ce n'est pas aussi simple qu'on peut
le penser
vous pourriez développer une section à
nombreuses paires fauteuil on pourrait
pas parce qu'on n'est pas les on n'a pas
les ressources pour pouvoir le faire
mais sur une solide et bien sûr mais bon
après
s'agit pas loin ce n'est pas une idée
qu'il faut faire c'est d'avoir si bien
il faut le faire après cette page
découverte on termine cette émission par
notre défi du jour le défi concerne
aujourd'hui le rugby je vous vois
sourire poli vénéré neuf ça vous
concerne l'équipe senior féminine de
montier bretonneux qui s'était déjà
prêté au jeu la dernière fois est encore
à l'honneur dans cette émission le défi
du jour consiste à toucher une bouteille
à 15 mètres en faisant une passe si elle
ne la touche pas elles sont éliminées à
regarder shufu j'ai 38 ans a fait à peu
près une dizaine d'années que je suis
libertine y est je suis apte à relever
le défi et le dire inquiète sur nos maux
j'ai 28 ans ça fait six ans que je suis
au club de montigny et je vais tenter de
toutes les classes et si possible et
gêné fritsch dit la frite j'ai 28 ans et
ça fait très ambitieux club mais je vais
te défoncer les à de carvalho mes
copines m'appelle zaza j'ai 26 ans et ça
fait une dizaine d'années que je suis au
club de montlouis et je vais tout faire
pour gagner ce défi
anne emery j'ai 34 ans je suis depuis
2007 au club de montigny et puis bah
c'est évident je fais éclater
sa mutuelle je gagne tout le temps non
mais c'est désolant parce que ça fait
pas longtemps que j'appris
l'entraînement ça fait plaisir que de
voir que j'arrive encore à faire des
passes s'est bien vengé pas faibli du
coût écologique c'est que j'ai ce
qu'elle avait perdu recommande d'écouter
des partenaires un peu trop faible c'est
la reprise
ça fait un peu plus puisque la saison à
c'est fini tout donc je souhaite dedans
olivier neyreneuf une réaction voire par
ce jeu vous êtes de bienvenue au mois de
juin à versailles et je constate que
l'égalité est pas forcément en fait
entre les hommes et les femmes parce que
le challenge qui était pas opposé à ce
moment là était compliqué il fallait
taper une transformation sur le poteau
pouvait toucher le poteau aura peut-être
avec les filles de montigny est alors le
y avait un club qu'il est passé avant
nous qui avait vous aviez arrêté le défi
parce que il avait vous tirez tirez
tirez se passait rien c'était le sky
rugby au baromètre les images non sens
où elle et versailles et ont mis peu de
temps pour toucher le poteau
effectivement donc voilà le défi avec a
remporté mais je pense que les filles
elle peut faire mieux encore que ça en
interne à la rue des sarts elle est
belle ambiance oui non si j'en connais
une sur les oiseaux sur le lot et donc
non il ya une très bonne ambiance tant
pis on ils sont toujours là pour deux
pour faire tous les défis moi je trouve
ça génial
vous avez beaucoup rire
moi j'adore les j'adore j'adore ces
petits défis que vous nous présentez
vous attend toujours pour pour en faire
un vélodrome attend on attend que le
championnat d'europe soit passé et on
verra ça après raul dernier mot c'est
toujours sympa de
dallier le ludique avec la technique
parce que ça reste est assez technique
de faire ça donc ça de rendre le sport
amusant
moi aussi je vous attend pour vous
mettre à cheval quand vous voulez aux
écuries les rendez vous sont pris la
lrai plein la chaîne devenue merci c'est
la fin de cette émission merci nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi 6
octobre pour un nouveau numéro de six
ans par les sports à bientôt sur tv fil